YUFENG GUO: The only thing
better than data is big data.
But getting your hands on large
data sets is no easy feat.
From unwieldy storage
options to difficulty
getting analytics tools to run
over your dataset properly,
large data sets can lead
to all sorts of struggles
when it comes to actually doing
something useful with them.
So what's a data
scientist to do?
Stay tuned to find out.
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we're going to check out
the BigQuery public datasets
and explore the amazing
world of open data.
We all love data, preferably
the more the merrier.
But as file sizes grow
and complexity increases,
it becomes increasingly
challenging to make
practical use of that data.
BigQuery public datasets are
datasets that Google BigQuery
hosts for you to
access and integrate
into your applications.
So this means that Google
pays for the storage
of these datasets and provides
public access to the data
via your cloud project.
You pay only for the queries
that you perform on the data.
Moreover, there
is a one-terabyte
per month free tier, making
getting started super easy.
Looking at the
public datasets page,
we can see that at the
time of this recording,
there are nearly
40 public datasets.
Each dataset, in
turn, has many tables.
Thousands of queries
from hundreds of projects
all over the world
are already making use
of these vast public datasets.
What's really neat, though,
is that each of these datasets
comes with a bit
of explanatory text
that helps you get started
with querying the data
and understanding its structure.
Let's take a look at example.
Here's the New York
City tree census.
The page shows us
how we can easily
find the answers
to questions like,
what are the most common tree
species in New York City?
And how have the tree
species changed since 1995
in New York City?
These are all accessible
by literally one click
from the docs page,
which opens right
into the BigQuery interface.
Another data set
that is quite amazing
is the Open Images dataset.
It contains approximately
nine million URLs,
along with metadata,
for images that
have been annotated with labels
spanning over 6,000 categories.
Using it, you can find answers
to your most pressing questions
about images on the web, like
how many images of a trolley
bus are in this dataset?
It's over 3,000.
But I digress.
BigQuery open datasets
is a great way
to explore public datasets and
practice your data analysis
skills.
Combined with tools that we've
looked at before, like Data
Lab, Facets, and TensorFlow,
you could really come up
with some awesome data science.
So what are you waiting for?
Head on over to the
Public Datasets page
and let your analysis run wild.
For more details and
examples, check out
the expanded blog
posts I've linked
to down below in
the description.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
And if you enjoyed
it, please like it
and consider subscribing to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, check out
BigQuery's public datasets,
and start querying away.